(upbeat music)
- Welcome back, everybody.
I'll say it every chance I get,
there is nothing more
than the Christmas spirit
and the holiday season.
I love it so much.
And Christmas in New York,
is there anything better?
It's magical, walking
around all the lights.
(audience cheers and claps)
It's chilly.
It's so beautiful.
I love it all, the lights, the music,
the time with family and friends.
And then there are the
presents, which we love to get,
but we also love giving.
That makes me feel even better.
So here to kick off our week long,
holiday gift guide extravaganza,
let's welcome back my friend, podcast host
and shopping expert
extraordinaire, Lawrence Zarian.
(Kelly clapping)
(audience cheers and clapping)
- Hi everybody, ready?
Three, Two, one, yeah!
(audience cheering and clapping)
- We actually have our "Kelly
Clarkson Show" elf, Odea
to help us out as well. Come on Odea.
(audience clapping and cheering)
But we are celebrating
Christmas in the Big Apple,
and each taxi here is
holding the perfect gift.
So let's reveal the first one, shall we?
- Now, Kelly, this is season
five with us together.
- Yes.
- And we're learning
about each other more and
more, baby step dating.
- Okay.
- So I have a question.
Are you a cafe latte or
a double espresso girl?
- Cafe latte.
- Oh, me too.
I love that.
- Yeah, it's a little,
I don't need the (kelly
lip trilling) extra.
- No, I don't.
No, I give that to you.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, no matter what your
coffee preference is,
you can have it at the touch
of a fingertip with this.
- Oh my God, oh my God, oh my God, woo.
(bells jingling)
(audience cheering)
- How good is this?
(audience clapping)
I know.
- All right.
- I think they're happy.
- I, it's coffee.
- I think they've got the,
(Lawrence lip trilling).
It is the Miele CM5300 whole
bean countertop coffee machine.
With just the touch of a button
make custom barista quality beverages
in the comfort of your own home.
(audience clapping)
This German engineered
system really does it all.
Single or double servings of
coffee, espresso, cappuccino
lattes, creamy milk
froth and so much more.
So all you have to do to
decide for Christmas is Kelly,
do you want your coffee with Kahlua
or do you want it with Amaretto?
- Actually, Amarula, it's really good.
(Lawrence laughing and clapping)
- Alright.
- It's South African
and it's really good.
- I'm I'm gonna let you do it.
Now, this is a serious piece
of machinery right here
and it is worth $1,400.
(audience gasping)
- [Kelly] All right, all right.
- Yeah.
- So, do you think anyone,
anyone in our audience would want one?
Do you think anybody?
(audience cheering)
Oh you would?
All right, well get your
kitchen counters ready
because you are all getting
your Miele coffee machine.
(audience cheering)
All right, lets' move onto the next one.
- Now Kelly, it's true.
This time of year, the
shopping, the baking,
the decorating, the finding
Lawrence the perfect gift.
- Yes.
- It can be stressful.
- So stressful.
- I know.
So you know what you give
people that you love?
Give them a little bit
of relaxation with this.
(bells jingling)
- I don't know what's happening.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- This is the Theragun Sense.
A massage device that can help you improve
everyday wellness.
That's right. Mondays,
Tuesdays, Wednesdays.
You get my point, right? All right.
(audience cheering)
This device will make your loved ones
feel better all year long.
Plus the best part, it's
lightweight, it's quiet,
and has a patented triangle design
that helps you treat more
than 80% of your body.
(audience cheering)
I know.
- I have one.
- It's such a good deal.
- I love them.
- Really?
- I have, yeah, I have the big
one and the small one. Yeah.
- Have you been stressed?
No.
- I just like to feel good.
I don't see anything wrong...
(audience laughing)
- Now, trust me, whoever
gets this gift will smile
and then say, ah.
Come here mama. Turn around.
- Yeah, do it, do it, do it, do it.
- Okay, three, two, get ready.
(Kelly and Lawrence aaghing)
- I'm so,
we're still children.
- How good is that?
It feels so good, right.
- It feels really good.
I like it, I like it.
- It's good, easy.
I'll massage you anytime.
- It's better someone else does it.
- Yeah, I know.
- All right.
Who wants to melt their
stress away with a Theragun?
(audience clapping and cheering)
Well perfect, you're
all going home with one.
(audience clapping and cheering)
I like this one.
All right, what's next? Final taxi.
- So, here's the thing.
Now Kelly, we all have those days
where we wanna work out
right? But it's just too cold.
- Do we? Yeah.
- We do.
No, no, we do right?
We have those days
where we wanna work out,
but you and I together. we're like,
"It's just too cold outside."
- Yeah.
- Or we're feeling lazy
or this is something that you and I do,
we sit there and we
daydream of vacationing,
of all the places we'd rather
be than where we are. Right?
- Kind of, unless you
wanna come to Montana,
then I just dream of being there.
- I was officially
invited to Montana, yes.
(audience clapping)
- So, we gotta get you
guys to get up and move
and you get to get up and move with this.
(Kelly whooping)
(Bells jingling)
- Have you seen this?
- No.
- I know,
- I own this.
- This is the best.
This is the best.
(audience continuing to cheer)
It's the Hydro rower.
This brings the on-water
experience of rowing
right into your home.
And you can still travel
the world from home with,
athlete led classes
filmed around the world.
And this is all the while
getting a full body workout
that's high energy and low impact.
Seriously, you can build, are you ready?
Strength and cardio in
less than 20 minutes, good.
(all clapping)
Are wanna do it again, I
wanna do it again. Ready?
I love it.
(audience clapping)
- I actually have this rower in my house.
I use this in my house.
I love this rower.
Anybody want one, anybody?
(audience cheering and clapping)
Every one of you is getting a Hydrow rower
plus a six month membership,
you're gonna love it.
(audience clapping and cheering)
Thank you again.
- Shall I do it?
- Yes.
- Ready, three.
- I'm ready, I'm ready.
Oh, Christmas.
Be sure to like, download and share
"You Are Beautiful with Lawrence Zarian".
Available on all podcast
streaming platforms.
Up next, I am singing with Teddy Swims,
so don't go away.
(upbeat music)